amis téléspectateurs bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur le plateau dès maintenant
l'émission qui revient avec plaisir et
avec vous sur l'actualité politique de
la semaine vous connaissez le principe
hashtag et maintenant si vous souhaitez
réagir aujourd'hui pour cette première
émission de l'année nous avons
sélectionné les meilleurs ils ont l'art
ils ont la manière ils sont très
intelligents en 2023 ne leur fait pas
peur du tout avec nous le redoutable
Jean-Luc mano bonjour bonjour enseignant
en communication fondateur du cabinet en
lit conseil le nombre redoutable pierre
Jacquemin est aussi avec nous rédacteur
en chef de politique bonjour Pierre
m'avoir la Une de politics cette semaine
elle est consacrée au retraites avec
nous Roselyne Bachelot ancienne ministre
bonjour vous sortez 682 jours 682 comme
le nombre de jours que vous avez passé
au ministère de la Culture sous Emmanuel
Macron vous racontez tout ça dans ce
journal de bord c'est à retrouver aux
éditions plomb Philippe manières bonjour
bonjour vous êtes co-fondateur et
président du cabinet va et Solis vous
êtes l'auteur du livre le pangolin est
l'ISF exactement le monde d'après nous
rend tous fous c'est publié aux éditions
de l'Observatoire dans cette émission on
se demandera jusqu'où la France doit
aller pour aider l'Ukraine on cherchera
ce que peut faire le Parti socialiste
pour céder lui-même on se penchera sur
l'avenir des frondeurs à la France
insoumise et sur le présent de nos
démocraties après la tentative de coup
de force au Brésil mais d'abord merci
président l'archet ça y est c'est parti
après plusieurs mois de bande-annonce le
gouvernement a dévoilé mardi les détails
de sa réforme des retraites l'âge légal
de départ qui est aujourd'hui de 62 ans
sera reculé à 64 ans d'ici 2030 à gauche
on dit non à droite on dit banco
compter du 1er septembre l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite sera relevé
progressivement de trois mois par an
pour atteindre 64 ans en 2030 je ne vois
pas comment on peut ne pas voter une
réforme qu'on a appelé de nos vœux
depuis des années je crois que ce qui a
abîmé la droite ce sont ces reniements
ces revirements l'ensemble des Français
concerné 85% d'entre eux sont opposés à
l'idée de travailler plus longtemps donc
il y a une majorité dans ce pays qui est
vend debout contre cette contre-réforme
parce que la réforme c'est d'améliorer
les conditions de vie des gens donc là
c'est une contre-réforme c'est une
régression Philippe c'est une régression
cette réforme non c'est pas une
régression c'est une un ajustement une
adaptation qui est rendue nécessaire par
l'évolution de la démographie elle est
même à mon avis très équilibrée voire
peut-être insuffisante moi c'est ça qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est à dire que vous
savez le livre blanc des retraites la
première fois où on a ouvert les yeux
sur cette réalité démographique qui
était déjà appréhendable depuis
longtemps puisque la démographie elle a
cette particularité que en gros commencé
aujourd'hui qui aura 80 ans dans 80 ans
modulo l'éventuelle troisième guerre
mondiale qui pourrait survenir donc on a
plein de choses qui peuvent jamais
arriver
en démographie donc en 88 89 90 on a
commencé à regarder le sujet de près et
family Livre blanc de Michel Rocas ça ne
nous rajeunit pas tout à fait et depuis
on a fait je crois 6 réformes donc
aucune n'a purgé le sujet et moi je
pense que c'était vraiment l'intérêt de
tous d'avoir une réforme qui permette de
penser que ça y est le régime est
équilibré on en parlera plus vous savez
c'est cette fameuse métaphore que j'aime
beaucoup de l'économiste Frédéric Bastia
quand il faut couper la queue du chien
on peut penser que c'est moins cruel de
le faire tranche par tranche mais c'est
une erreur et là j'ai peur que ce soit
c'est c'est pas mal hein c'est mais et
c'est équilibré c'est pas mal on a
beaucoup avancé mais je crains qu'il ne
failli revenir ce qui est franchement à
mon avis une bêtise pour la démocratie
et pour le débat public si on pouvait
tourner la page là dessus définitivement
ça serait pas mal car c'est une réforme
nécessaire modifier ne serait-ce que de
dire que c'est une réforme nécessaire
c'est déjà un parti pris et c'est déjà
un choix politique de l'assurer c'est de
l'arithmétique c'est de je sais pas je
je pense que on va beaucoup se
concentrer sur des débats d'économistes
nous ne sommes pas économistes personnes
autour de cette table n'est économie
c'est donc je pense que personne n'est
capable de justifier point par point
ligne par ligne la raison pour laquelle
il faudra absolument faire une référence
une réforme en tout cas on a tous même
constat c'est qu'effectivement on a
encore aujourd'hui un système de
retraite qui est profondément
inégalitaire donc sans doute faut-il oui
ajuster transformer rénové repenser
notre manière de de faire fonctionner
notre système de retraite mais je trouve
qu'on prend les mauvais indicateurs
c'est à dire qu'on a en tête il y a une
espèce d'obsession permanente à la
question de la dette à la question de la
crise à la question de la croissance etc
vous voyez les projections sont sans
cesse décrié celles du corps le comité
et le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites sans cesse décrié parce qu'on
ils sont ils font des analyses sur la
base de chiffres de croissance
je veux juste vous montrer un truc je
vais vous montrer justement ces
prévisions de des déficits et on y
reviendra après les prévisions du
déficit pour 2027 c'est moins
8,3 milliards d'euros pour la période
2027 2050 on est sur un déficit d'une
dizaine de milliards d'euros et 2050 on
serait c'est encore des prévisions en
excédant budget 2050 c'est une dixième
de milliard euros par an oui je pense
juste que c'est pas un débat qui
intéresse les Français et que quand je
dis qu'on se trompe de d'indicateurs
c'est que l'indicateur qui doit nous qui
doit nous enfin en tout cas quand on
fait de la politique j'ai le sentiment
que quand on fait des indicateurs ça
devrait être le syndicateur de santé on
doit se réjouir réjouissons-nous qu'on
est en France le deuxième pays d'Europe
qui a les personnes âgées qui vivent le
mieux après la la retraite
on devrait avoir des indicateurs de
santé et de de aujourd'hui on a des
indicateurs de croissance faut penser le
PIB il faut penser la croissance pour
cette salade il faut juste penser les
indicateurs de croissance le sujet n'est
pas un sujet d'économie c'est un sujet
politique c'est un sujet de choix de
société et quand on veut se donner les
raisons les moyens de garder un système
de retard tel qu'on l'a aujourd'hui qui
plutôt un bon système donnons-nous les
moyens trop on des recettes et arrêtons
de dire qu'il y a des déficits croisés
c'est un choix politique ou une
nécessité économique je pense même que
il faut réfléchir
beaucoup plus en contexte et je trouve
très intéressant de voir ce que ce débat
a révélé comme désaffiliation à la
valeur travail
c'est le point fondamental qui explique
d'ailleurs aussi les réticences de
l'opinion publique à aller dans cette
réflexion sur sur les retraites
pour en 1990 on n'est pas très loin je
vous conseille de lire la remarquable
remarquable des bas entre Cynthia Fleury
et Jérôme Fourquet pour 60% des Français
la valeur travail était primordiale on
est à 24% aujourd'hui avec un
effondrement massif chez les jeunes il
faut dire aussi qu'on sort si vous
voulez dire qu'on est devenu des
flemmards
on peut très bien considérer que le
travail n'est pas important et pourtant
travailler beaucoup
ça n'a rien à voir c'est une question de
conscient et d'inconscient collectif et
on peut pas raisonner la question sur
les retraites si on se se passe pas dans
cette vision globale du rapport des
Français au travail en plus tous ces
événements ont été accélérés puisque
pendant la période de confinement il y a
11 millions de Français qui sont restés
chez eux à ne pas travailler je dis pas
des gens en télétravail je passe du
chômage partiel c'est à dire que pendant
plusieurs mois des gens d'un changement
d'un rapport au travail de manière
générale changement du rapport au
travail et si on veut moi je suis à la
fois d'accord avec Philippe Manière
quand il dit il y a un problème
paramétrique de financement des
retraites mais je suis aussi d'accord
avec Pierre Jacquemin en disant Macron
mettre dans une case absurde
j'allais dire je vomi que ça
il est d'accord avec les septé je suis
d'accord avec Pierre quand il dit que
c'est pas seulement un problème
technique mais que c'est un problème
politique au sens noble du terme quel
rapport avons-nous comment comment
vivons-nous ce rapport au travail
la société d'aujourd'hui
parce que il y a du vrai évidemment dans
dans tout ce qui dit d'abord moi je
trouve qu'il y a pas de réforme
il y a des mesures un certain nombre de
mesures mais c'est pas une réforme oui
en réalité il y a une mesure d'âge qui
est l'accélération de la réforme
Touraine voilà et puis il y a des
mesures d'accompagnement qui sont assez
justes et qui notamment la mesure phare
qui est les 1200 euros minimum pour les
plus basses retraites
bénéficiaires
de 50% des gens ça ça
s'équilibre mais moi je pense que la
réforme c'est celle qui a été arrêtée
celle du premier mandat de de d'Emmanuel
Macron qui était une pour le coup une
retraite systémique et qui elle avait du
avec du sens on les met où on n'aimait
pas mais en tout cas il y avait une
réforme qui portait
pas de sens ce sont des mesures donc on
n'est pas non plus on est la
prolongation
du du du système c'est le même système
en cotisant un peu plus longtemps et en
augmentant les les en augmentant les les
les comment dire les trimestres
nécessaires et on augmentant le revenu
des les les plus bas ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point je suis d'accord
vraiment avec alors si je vois d'accord
avec quelqu'un ce serait plutôt avec
Roselyne sur le point avec les deux
autres transitivité on est contenter
allez-y allez-y jamais
[Musique]
sur le point sur le point de la de ce
que ça veut dire du point de vue du
point de vue sociétal c'est vrai que
quand on va en Allemagne en Italie au
Portugal ou la durée de travail est plus
longue on n'a pas le sentiment non plus
que ça crée un
accès de déprime comparé à la France la
France est un pays plus déprimé dont la
population est plus déprimée qu'ailleurs
je ne dis pas que leur système vaut
mieux c'est pas ce que je suis en train
de dire mais en tout cas par rapport il
y a pas il y a on voit pas un drame dans
ces pays à avoir des retraites à 64 65
c'est pas vécu comme ça les syndicats on
va écouter les syndicats après les
annonces
d'Élisabeth les pauvre en Allemagne
qu'en France beaucoup beaucoup plus on
va parler de la réaction des syndicats
ce que je veux dire c'est que le en
France c'est vrai que la mesure d'âge
amène à des conflits et des pas accepté
par la population voilà c'est une
réalité qu'on a parlé dans un instant
Philippe pour la première fois depuis 12
ans toutes les organisations syndicales
appellent à se mobiliser dans la rue
jeudi prochain la CFDT est elle aussi
vent debout contre la réforme écoutez
très fort mais elle propose un report de
l'âge légal de départ en retraite c'est
la mesure la plus injuste et la plus
redistributive qui soit et il est normal
que les organisations réagissent on a
toujours dit qu'on était opposés à cette
réforme c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
ensemble on n'a pas un appelant cette
date de du 19 janvier où on appelle à
des manifestations pour que les
travailleurs puissent faire entendre
leur mécontentement elle va se jouer
dans la rue cette réforme Philippe
franchement moi j'ai renoncé depuis un
certain temps à faire de la météo
sociale parce que je pense que c'est
imprudent on ne peut pas savoir il y a
assez de bonnes raisons de penser que
oui tous les syndicats plan ensemble à
l'action on peut avoir un effet assez
puissant on peut se dire aussi que
personne n'est vraiment surpris parce
qu'il y a été annoncé que ce qui est
annoncé n'est pas non plus
révolutionnaire tu vas juste m'arrêter
un sur un tout petit point là-dessus
parce que je pense ça n'a pas été assez
vu si on n'avait rien fait la réforme
Touraine qui comme vous le savez
accroître tous les ans le nombre de
trimestre qu'on doit avoir ça tous les
trois ans le nombre de trimestres qu'on
doit faire régulièrement au fil du temps
le nombre de trimestres qu'on doit
cotiser
dans 12 ans 13 ans exactement à là où on
en est après la réforme autrement dit
quand vous regardez il y a 12 cordes qui
sont concernés par la réforme 12 les
gens qui sont nés entre le deuxième
semestre et 1961 et ceux qui sont et
ceux qui sont nés à la femme 1972 tous
les autres avant après ça change rien
pour eux parce que ceux qui sont nés
avant de toute façon ils auraient été
rattrapés par l'augmentation du nombre
de trimestres à cotisés au titre niveau
de la réforme Touraine et tous ceux qui
sont avant ils sont pas concernés parce
qu'ils sont pas concernés par la fin
donc à l'arrivée vous avez quand même me
semble-t-il une espèce de de réaction
syndicale et politique horrifiés sur le
thème ah mais c'est dingue c'est vrai
comme ils étaient très justement
Jean-Luc ça n'est pas vraiment une
réforme au sens systémique mais ça n'est
même pas une réforme très ambitieuse au
sens de l'impact sur les gens puisque
encore une fois 12 générations vont
devoir travailler entre 1 et 8
trimestres supplémentaires au fond quand
même il y a pas de quoi
vous expliquer ça moi ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est justement ce que ça
signe la faiblesse du monde syndical la
réaction qu'on vient de voir voilà parce
qu'ils sont entre eux dans une sorte de
course à l'échalote et là finalement
l'attitude de la CFDT est totalement
incompréhensible dans cette affaire
parce que
dans un savais pas participé à la
dernière mobilisation au mois d'octobre
participé à la dernière mobilisation et
finalement moyennant un peu de de
j'allais dire de négociation en
particulier sur l'affaire des 34 ans qui
est un vrai problème parce que ça ça
apparaît comme une injustice et
véritablement d'une certaine façon ça
plombe la communication du gouvernement
cette affaire de 44 ans la CFDT aurait
pu se mobiliser sur cette affaire ce
point-là sur ce point-là négocier et
apparaître comme un syndicat informateur
ils sont ils sont dans une course dans
une emploie ce terme un peu trivial
pardon de course à l'échalote parce que
les syndicats français sont en position
de faiblesse et quand on les compare à
la capacité de négociation des syndicats
allemands par exemple c'est la
différence est tout à fait frappant
alors les syndicats peut-être mais quand
on demande aux Français s'ils sont pour
cette réforme ils sont contre
un sondage je vais vous montrer le
sondage est là pour BFM TV 59% des
Français sont opposés à la réforme des
retraites telles qu'elle a été présentée
par Elisabeth borne à l'exception des
retraités toutes toutes les catégories
professionnelles s'y opposent largement
Jean-Luc il y a quand même
il y a une colère sociale que vous
percevez que vous sentez venir ou pas il
y a un malaise social il y a du des
formes de colère il y a même des formes
de de violences latente donc évidemment
c'est une situation très inflammable
pour citer les auteurs qu'on ne cite
plus comme disait Mao une étincelle peut
mettre le feu à la plaine il y a il y a
évidemment une situation extrêmement
extrêmement complexe mais je vais
revenir
Roselyne a raison de parler de la
faiblesse structurelle des syndicats on
va dire qu'il y a une faiblesse
structurelle aussi du président de la
République dans son approche des
syndicats parce que il a quand même raté
la CFDT on va on va se le dire
depuis longtemps que sur la question des
retraites il y avait une règle pour y
arriver il fallait suivre l'étoile du
Berger
le patron la CFDT le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que ça pas été le cas qui que
le le l'attitude du président de la
République n'a pas perdu
mais c'est pas une question de le traité
de soyez c'est de l'écouter de
l'entendre et de regarder quel compromis
on peut faire avec des syndicats
réformistes même si dans le front
syndical qui qui est engagé là on va
commencer à voir des différences on
entend ce matin déjà des différences ces
jours-ci des différences de vocabulaire
entre la CGT qui dit on va couper le
pétrole on va arrêter de raffiner etc et
la CFDT qui dit on va faire une
manifestation des coups de ce monstre
pour montrer l'opposition
c'est une opposition à l'effort elle est
unitaire mais elle n'a pas le même
langage guerrier des deux côtés est-ce
que les choses peuvent bien se passer
entre guillemets dans la rue est-ce
qu'un dialogue social est possible
aujourd'hui et bien où on est déjà trop
loin trop tard il y a plus de dialogue
social enfin je veux bien entendre
Macron en tout cas
bien sûr d'ailleurs c'est en cela que le
gouvernement n'a pas fait le choix du
dialogue social parce que s'il y avait
bien un sujet sur lequel la CFDT était
prête à avancer c'était sur les
questions de pénibilité le seul propos
ou sur lequel la première ministre a
renvoyé à la concentration c'est
précisément sur la pénibilité mais ça
fait combien de temps qu'on négocie que
les syndicats négocient ces questions-là
on connaît la position de la salle d'été
sur la question de la pénibilité qu'on
me qu'il faut rajouter des critères
qu'il faut renforcer les critères de
pénibilité de prise en compte de la
pénibilité dans le monde du travail donc
Emmanuel Macron a encore fait et surtout
fait le choix de la droite il aurait pu
faire le choix de la CFDT il a fait le
choix de la droite pour s'assurer le
confort des voix des députés de droit
totalement imaginer une majorité à
gauche sur cette réforme sincèrement
mais alors là c'est là où je pense que
vous vous trompez vous vous trompez si
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron avait dit on
va faire une réforme j'ai entendu le
j'ai entendu la contestation j'ai
entendu les syndicats et je refuse qu'il
y ait une unité syndicale et je vais
prendre le parti de la CFDT la CFDT dit
quoi je ne veux pas toucher à l'âge mais
je suis prête à discuter sur
l'allongement des annuités et la
question de la pénibilité bon ben là
vous trouvez une partie du Parti
socialiste au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale qui était qui pouvait être qui
pouvait suivre ça donc Emmanuel Macron
fait le choix de la droite et il fait le
choix à droite et pourquoi la droite
fait le choix du gouvernement parce que
sans doute derrière il y a un grand
projet auquel Emmanuel Macron tient le
projet de loi azili immigration et sans
doute
le sujet de la mobilisation pardon
Rosine le suivi la mobilisation je pense
que je trouve en tout cas en tant que
Monsieur berger qui a un discours qui
est quand même très déterminé qui a très
envie d'aller jusqu'au bout les deux
auront un engagement en plus et ont
surtout une ligne de mire qui est sans
doute la réélection par leur élection
parce qu'ils mettent en jeu leur leur
successeur donc il y a tout ça qui est
en ligne de compte qu'ils ont intérêt à
faire réussir cette mobilisation
j'ajoute une dernière chose ça fait
beaucoup de choses que j'ajoute en
dernière chose
par en retraite à 65 ans qu'on appelle
des lacs des gamins de 15 ans qui
justement vont être pénalisés parce que
finalement quand on refuse de réformer
les retraites ça veut dire qu'on fait
payer le déficit par nos enfants et non
pas par les gens qui cotisent mais je
trouve il y a des choses mais qui sont
absolument absolument lunaires je il y a
un rapport qui est très intéressant qui
paraît aujourd'hui de l'Institut des
politiques publiques qui regardent les
choses finement je voudrais en revenir
au fond de la réforme et qui dit
finalement ce seront les plus modestes
qui seront les moins touchés par la
réforme bien sûr et ça c'est un élément
tout à fait important et qu'on ne
souligne pas assez d'abord parce que on
ne touche pas à l'âge du départ de à la
retraite sans décote ce qui avait été
très important en 2010 et ça c'est très
important parce que sur les carrières
hachées ça permet il y a pas de
différence sur les carrières longues et
on ne touche pas au départ à 62 ans pour
les personnes invalides handicapées qui
ne sont pas en position qui sont inapte
au travail 15 secondes
de la gauche un certain nombre de
d'incohérences j'en relais vue en
particulier quand et les filles nous
disent
regardez il y a pas besoin de mesures
parce que la situation est bonne ils
oublient que la situation est bonne
parce que des réformes ont eu déjà ils
étaient déjà composé
c'est formidable la preuve on était
contre ces moyens c'est pas très honnête
parce que ce que dit la gauche c'est
qu'elle a un autre mode de financement
du projet de retraite on va parler
largement de la gauche vous avez très
envie de parler de la gauche on va en
reparler c'est grâce aux réforme qui ont
été prises
sur la gauche voilà je vous demande à
vous arrêter parce qu'on va beaucoup
beaucoup parler de la gauche ensuite
direction le Brésil à présent ou
dimanche dernier des centaines de
partisans de bolsonaro ont pris d'assaut
les principaux de pouvoir il refuse
d'accepter l'élection du président Lula
qui a été investie le 1er janvier c'est
maintenant l'heure de trouver et de
poursuivre les responsables
ces voyous que l'on peut appeler des
fanatiques nazis des fanatiques
staliniens ou mieux encore pasteliens
mais des fanatiques fascistes ont fait
quelque chose encore jamais vu dans
l'histoire de ce pays
il faut que ces personnes soient punies
de manière exemplaire que ces personnes
soient punies de manière à ce que plus
personne n'ose avec le drapeau national
sur le dos ou en portant le t-shirt de
l'équipe brésilienne prétendre être
nationaliste prétendre être brésilien
Jean-Luc comment vous qualifiez ce qui
s'est passé dimanche dernier
un mouvement voilà Trump montré
l'exemple bolsonaro qui a été toujours
son son élève son disciple
le suit mais c'est globalement
bien sûr bien sûr c'est une entreprise
de coup d'état par assurrection
factieuse on va dire parce que coup
d'État surtout en Amérique latine les
gold PC c'est en général l'armée qui
intervient et là l'armée est restée
complice dans la région de Brasilia à
l'évidence sur les manifestations mais
pas actives donc on peut pas dire que
c'est un coup d'état traditionnel mais
oui il y a un mouvement à l'évidence est
une démonstration factieuse et c'est une
tendance qui se développe dans dans
beaucoup de pays où les les mouvements
de protestation sont souvent ils
libéraux et et deviennent des des le
populisme nourrit la négation de la
démocratie et donc les démocraties
vacillent vous avez fait le parallèle
avec le Capitole du 6 janvier 2021 vous
voyez aussi ce parallèle justifié alors
bien sûr il y a cette espèce d'effet de
mimétisme bolsonaro Trump pensait qu'il
y a des liens pour dire le moins mais
au-delà moi je pense que ce sont
simplement deux symptômes d'un phénomène
majeur que personnellement j'avais pas
du tout vu venir qui est une mise en
cause assez générale dans toutes les
grandes démocraties depuis je dirais
maintenant une bonne dizaine d'années de
quelque chose qui nous semblait être
naturel définitif admis par tous qui est
ce qu'on appelle la démocratie
représentative c'est à dire que j'ai lis
des gens qui vont me représenter à qui
je délègue ma capacité d'expression et
je m'incline devant le résultat des
urnes et je m'incline devant les
décisions qui sont prises par par mes
représentants ça c'est quelque chose
ça nous semble être l'oxygène qu'on
respirait encore une fois jusqu'à la fin
des temps ça c'est il y a on le voit
d'ailleurs de toutes sortes de manières
vous avez de plus en plus cette mode des
conférences de citoyens conférence
citoyenne c'est là qui prétend en
quelque sorte substituée à la démocratie
représentative une forme de démocratie
directe ou de démocratie directe
déléguée avec tirage au sort et tout ça
ça va dans le même sens de la mise en
cause de l'alimentation représentative
pour être très honnête je vais être un
tout petit dernier point sur ce sur ce
sujet ce que nous venons d'avoir le
débat d'avoir auprès précédemment sur la
question de la réforme des retraites et
symptomatique de ce que nous ne sommes
pas complètement immune parce qu'en fait
la question qu'on se posait sans vouloir
la formuler de cette manière c'était
est-ce que la rue peut amener à ce que
ce qui sera décidé parce qu'on sait que
ce sera décidé par le Parlement ne soit
pas mis en oeuvre ce qui dans le fond
est un peu une question comparable dans
les rappelez vous quand je crois que
c'était le moment de Villepin un texte
avait été régulièrement voté par les
deux assemblées avait été promulgués et
le président de la République d'ailleurs
est une femme grave politiquement est
venu à la télévision pour dire qu'il
serait pas bébé
notre démocratie sur la démocratie
politique il y a des mots sur la
démocratie sociale aussi il n'est pas
bien supportable que des mouvements
sociaux puissent mettre en cause une
décision fut-elle prise majoritairement
naturel par le par le Parlement sinon on
dit aux syndicats rentrer à la maison
vous n'avez qu'un rôle de cogestion et
vous ne pouvez pas avoir un rôle de
contestation donc je suis pas
complètement contestation bien sûr c'est
les libertés publiques
en cause là en ce moment-là dans la
première partie de ce que vous avez dit
et parfaitement juste il y a même la
question de la notion du vote qui est
mise en je suis très intéressé de voir
qui comprit et pas du tout dans les
mêmes termes naturellement mais certains
nombre de forces politiques ni l'utilité
du vote sur le plan interne
[Musique]
Jean-Luc vous m'avez tendu une perche
ben oui on va entendre un invité vous
savez bien je suis là déjà amical c'est
très amical un invité était sur ce
plateau il y a quelques jours il a
condamné évidemment ce qui s'est passé
au Brésil il en a profité pour faire
quelques tactes à ses adversaires
politiques écoutez ça peut arriver dans
n'importe quel pays je mets en garde
également je mets en garde également les
partis politiques que ça soit en Europe
ou en France il y a des tentations des
fois de remettre en cause la légitimité
politique
il y a eu des tentations on voit bien
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de la part
notamment de LFI je palais nommer mais
il y a eu une tentation à un moment
donné de d'expliquer que la légitimité
des des élus étaient remises en cause
pour telle et telle raison
donc il faut faire attention mon pierre
est-ce qu'une un tel coup de force est
possible envisageable chez nous en
France
là dans l'immédiat je ne crois pas en
revanche c'est des signes qui
effectivement ne trompent pas et qui
doivent nous interroger d'abord ce qui
s'est passé aux États-Unis comme ce qui
s'est passé au Brésil doivent nous
interroger sur
la rapidité avec laquelle une démocratie
peut vaciller et d'ailleurs ce qui s'est
passé au Brésil n'est pas derrière nous
je pense qu'il y a encore des points de
vigilance et il faut être encore très
attentif à ce qu'il va se passer dans
les prochaines semaines au Brésil et
peut-être ailleurs d'ailleurs mais ça te
dit quelque chose de ce qu'est ce
national populisme de ce que c'est cette
extrême droite mais même si je sais bien
qu'aujourd'hui on a plus le droit de
dire et de qualifier ce que sont des
gens quand même il y a de l'extrême
gauche aussi dans certains mouvements
là ce que je crois pas je crois pas
qu'aujourd'hui l'extrême gauche menace
quelques démocraties que ce soit ça
n'est pas le sujet
de nazis
je pense qu'il y a du fascisme dans les
mouvements factieux qui sont aujourd'hui
à l'oeuvre dans les au Brésil comme ça a
été le cas aux États-Unis et en France
là où je pense qu'il y a pas de
imminente il y a un point de vigilance à
avoir jusque sur ce que c'est que le
National populiste que sur ce que c'est
que l'extrême droite et je voudrais dire
à Monsieur séjourner quand même parce
que je vois bien qu'ici aujourd'hui la
gauche qui attise un peu la rue pour
essayer de faire monter la pression
sociale et qui pourrait arriver selon
lui jusqu'au port du pouvoir exploiter
l'Assemblée nationale ou l'Élysée ce qui
ne s'est absolument jamais vu j'ai
jamais vu personne de la France
insoumise de demander d'aller squatter
le bureau de Monsieur Macron en revanche
que j'ai vu c'est des policiers qui
étaient sous les fenêtres des députés il
y a quelques années encore il y a quoi
deux trois ans dire que le problème de
la France était le poster un problème de
de la justice c'est enfin là il y a des
risques il y a des risques de dérive
factieuses oui qui doivent
est-ce qu'il y a des risques de dérive
ces mouvements
spontanéistes qui sont très forts dans
la société à une histoire d'extrême
droite non pas que je nie la puissance
de l'extrême droite dans certains de ces
débats c'est plus général mais c'est en
fait beaucoup plus général on l'a vu
dans les mouvements antivax on l'a vu au
moment du mouvement des gilets jaunes ou
clairement certains gilets jaunes
voulaient marcher sur l'Élysée et où il
y avait des affiches quand même avec la
tête de Macron au bout d'une pique
d'angè ne vient pas de l'extrême droite
c'est ce que vous je dis ne viens pas
seulement de l'extrême droite si on
réduit ce qui est en train de se passer
dans les sociétés démocratiques qui
rejoint la lassitude l'enchassement des
crises que dont nous parlions au début
du débat sur les retraites on se trompe
de diagnostic et ça ça faut pas jouer
les Fiero parce que ça existe ça existe
partout dans toutes nos sociétés où on
ne se reconnaît plus dans les corps
intermédiaires on vient d'emporter le
diagnostic avec les syndicats avec les
partis politiques avec les structures
religieuses et avec le surgissement des
réseaux sociaux
c'est un phénomène qu'on peut rapprocher
du doute auquel sortent maintenant
l'expression Roselyne parlait des
antivax l'expression de fait
scientifique ça vous avez maintenant je
crois plus de 10% des français qui sont
platistes ça nous fait rire quand c'est
les Américains vous avez vu
les gens
détruites par des extraterrestres
comme ça vous êtes tout ça c'est là où
je pense qu'on a raison de penser que
c'est un phénomène beaucoup plus large
c'est-à-dire des choses qui sont
évidentes la démocratie est là elle est
bonne elle est là pour l'éternité les
faits scientifique sont là et ils ne
souffrent pas la réplique sur la base
d'opinion non documentée ça c'est
terminé donc on est on est rentré dans
une phase où il faut défendre ceux qui
semblait pour le coup des acquis la
démocratie la science ce sont des forces
de l'esprit voilà
jusqu'où ira la fronde à la France
insoumise c'est notre troisième thème
plusieurs historiques figurines
historiques du mouvement conteste la
nouvelle direction de LFI une nouvelle
direction incarnée par Manuel bon par un
très proche de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
désigné à l'unanimité mais sans vote
coordinateur du mouvement en
remplacement d'Adrien de son côté
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle
leur dit ben débrouillez-vous sans moi
maintenant
et je ne suis pas candidat ma succession
est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je
dise de France
intellectuel vous ne serez pas candidat
quoi qu'il arrive en 2027 ce sont les
circonstances qui font les candidatures
tout le monde le sait je n'ai pas été
candidat à trois fois par un effet de
mon ambition notamment la dernière fois
c'était pas l'envoyer au moment où j'en
avais le plus envie c'était les
circonstances qui faisait de moi la
personne à d'autres qu'est-ce qui va se
passer en 2027 les circonstances vont
permettre de désigner quelqu'un Jean-Luc
vous êtes docteur s en mélangeant qui
raccroche ou pas là je comprends pas ce
qu'il a dit
Mélenchon c'est entre l'hypothèque et
l'épée de Damoclès selon qui on est en
réalité on voit bien qu'il qu'il se
refuse à dire c'est fini est-ce qu'il
refuse à dire c'est terminé parce que au
fond il veut continuer dans le jeu et il
sait qu'en France quand on dit je joue
plus dans le film présidentiel
et qu'on alors qu'on y a été on est
quasiment mort politiquement ça existe
plus c'est comme le président qui dit
après au premier mandat je me représente
plus c'est impossible donc il y a un jeu
tactique puis il y a peut-être toujours
autour de dans sa tête l'idée que ça
pourrait être jouable mais d'ailleurs
les gens qui sont dans la dynamique
d'être d'avoir c'est pas rien d'être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle je
vais faire
les 30 secondes de psychiatre de
psychiatre psychanalytique c'est pas
pareil que d'être candidat à la
députation que d'être candidat à une
mairie c'est la présidence de la
République et je crois que ça vous
marque à vie et qu'en réalité le même le
même ceux qui ont été président de la
République et qui ont été battus ils ont
dans un coin de leur tête que peut-être
il pourrait y avoir un moment l'idée du
retour parce que on parce que on
n'arrête jamais on arrête jamais de
l'être en fait et même quand nous on se
dit
Sarkozy Hollande on se dit Noé a priori
quoi il y a il faudrait qu'il se passe
un truc absolument dément
et point de leur tête ils continuent à
penser et là-dessus c'est un acte de
normalité Mélenchon n'est pas différent
de ce que je viens en tout cas il y a
des frondeurs aujourd'hui à la France
insoumise il y a combien de temps
aujourd'hui Pierre à l'intérieur de ce
parti de ce mouvement spécialiste de la
France
vous expliquer qu'il y a pas de camp
parce que d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle il a théorisé l'idée du
mouvement gazeux c'est que précisément
il voulait pas revenir aux années du
Parti socialiste avec les un courant de
courant trois courants les sous-courants
les machins etc donc lui la question de
la démocratie c'est effectivement un
sujet qui l'a qui l'a essayé de
théoriser autour de ce mouvement gazeux
qui l'a constitué autour de la France
insoumise moi je me souviens quand même
juste pour rebondir ce que vous venez de
dire c'est que Mélenchon c'est quand
même l'homme de la de la de la punchline
en tout cas du bon du bon parler on aime
l'entendre et je me souviens qu'en 2012
il disait cette phrase après l'élection
présidentielle je suis votre héritage
commun je trouvais cette phrase assez
joli ce qui donnait déjà un peu à voir
que peut-être
qu'est-ce qu'il dit en 2022 il dit
faites mieux comme si justement
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de penser que ce que vous
évoquez comme étant des divisions même
si je crois pas que c'est des divisions
il y a des dividendes il y a des
divergences bonjour aujourd'hui je sais
qu'on aime beaucoup parler de stratégie
popol de politique politicienne entre
nous mais il y a pas il y a pas l'ombre
d'une épaisseur de cigarettes de papier
de papier de cigarette qui sur le sur
les sujets politiques entre les autres
et donc les divisions d'ordre
stratégique démocratie à la France
insoumise justement comment fonctionne
la France insoumise en interne écoutez
Mathilde pano présidente du groupe LFI à
l'Assemblée nationale elle explique
comment et bien manuel Bompard a été
désigné
dans la Réunion puisque on anime si
quelqu'un si quelqu'un n'est pas unanime
à ce moment-là c'est c'est dit
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui serait venu sur votre
plateau vous expliquer que et donc on
peut le dire quand on est pas d'accord
mais en dehors de la Réunion
mais je vous assure qu'il y a une
personne dans la Réunion qui était en
désaccord avec cela mais comment vous le
savez mais la Réunion il y a 21
personnes vous savez on ne fait pas
genre je suis coordinateur et puis après
c'est fini enfin faut arrêter enfin ça
ça ne marche pas comme ça notre dans
notre mouvement il y a il y a il y a un
point à l'ordre du jour qui s'appelle
qui va faire l'animation de la
coordination des espaces et donc à
l'unanimité des membres qui étaient là
c'est Manuel Bompard qui a été du chef
du coup pour dire oui
faut arrêter au fait
de ramer t'attaque la falaise dans ces
collector c'est quand c'est
il y a pas de victoire politique sans
victoire idéologique étant donné que la
construction de Jean-Luc Mélenchon a été
quand même une construction idéologique
qui a été peuplé de Nomi et de et de
contradiction parce que à la fois bâtir
la France insoumise et bâtir la nuque
c'était de toute façon une sorte de de
difficulté de torsion extrêmement
forte et on a l'impression aussi que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est allé au bout
de ce parcours idéologique et que les
choses l'intervention ne m'a-t-il
panneau l'intervention de clémentine
Ottin l'intervention d'autres d'ailleurs
le malaise qui a autour de l'affaire
d'Adrien catenas tout ça est en train
évidemment de de de causer à des
malaises exactement parti politique
c'est pas c'est pas une formation
normale bien sûr enfin le terme j'aime
pas beaucoup le de Norman j'ai dit entre
guillemets
d'Emmanuel Macron ça fonctionne à peu
près pareil
ce sont des mouvements ils s'assume
comme étant des mouvements c'est la
question importante est-ce qu'il y a une
pathologie spécifique alors il faut
commencer par dire que tous les autres
partis qui ont des élections c'est des
élections qui sont quand même assez
largement arrangé le suspense ne fait
pas partie de la politique sort de ce
corps voilà c'est ça on peut pas
vraiment imaginer c'est pas la
démocratie je pense que ça à son
importance tout le monde vous allez dire
fin je veux pas être trop mais tout le
monde
manifeste son adhésion à l'idée que dans
une dans un système qui fonctionne bien
il y a un suffrage libre et il y a quand
même quelqu'un qui est désigné sur la
base d'un vote il y a pardon de le dire
dans la dans la dans la tradition
politique de l'extrême gauche il y a pas
véritablement un rôle très considérable
qui est donné à l'expression libre d'un
suffrage en quelques exemples on sait
bien que dans les âgés dans les fans etc
c'est toujours à votre amas levée on
préférait crever que de faire voter les
gens à bulletin secret parce qu'on sait
bien qu'on pourrait perdre donc il y a
quand même dans cette famille politique
une très grande tradition d'austérité de
méfiance pour une raison simple
d'ailleurs qui est parfaitement
compréhensible c'est si on pense qu'on
est le camp du bien et qu'il faut
l'emporter toute façon parce que c'est
le bien des travailleurs c'est
l'héritage on a pas besoin de s'embêter
à voir
si vous voulez donc il y a cette
problématique particulière et qu'on voit
ressortir en l'occurrence c'est c'est ce
que des climat a-t-il panneaux est
complètement surréaliste malgré tout ces
collecteurs mais Rosine a raison
d'insister sur un point c'est que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'a dit souvent hier
soir dans l'émission qui était un peu
longue et pas très je trouve mais
c'était au moins c'était un pari
osé du service public parce que c'est
vrai qu'il est à l'élu sur le fond des
sujets et c'était plutôt de haute
voltige avec une audience qui est pas
très bien c'est pas le sujet mais
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il a il a
beaucoup dit laissez-moi terminer ma
construction idéologique va construire
une théorique c'est plus posé comme
étant un espèce d'intellectuel hier soir
que un chef de guerre mais Jean-Luc
Mélenchon était quand même étant quand
même une carte de cortiquées
politiquesment on voit bien que quand
même que tout ce qui se passe pas besoin
de la France insoumise les espèces de
division les gardent une succession tout
ça ça pourrait peut-être bien la ranger
un moment donné parce qu'il finira par
être celui qui mettra tout le monde
d'accord
vous mettez dans une même dans une même
salle des sociaux-démocrates des
froquets des des
écologistes des spontanéistes
et des trots à la fin c'est des
trosquises qui gagnent toujours et donc
parce que ils savent mieux faire et donc
l'inspiration généralement
son inspiration donc elle est pas
démocratique tout simplement
c'est la base du Dropkick de pas être
démocratique puisqu'elle considère que
le fonctionnement des autres parties est
un fonctionnement bourgeois et donc on
va parler la même partie donc ça va vous
dire on est dans une situation là-dessus
assez assez logique le Parti socialiste
dans tout ça oui vous savez ce parti qui
était autrefois à la première formation
de France et bien ce jeudi les militants
ont voté pour le premier tour d'un
congrès décisif Olivier Faure était
opposé à deux concurrents qui lui
reprochent son alliance avec la France
insoumise pour former la nupes l'actuel
patron du PS est arrivé largement en
tête du scrutin écoutez-le parler de
cette alliance à gauche c'était lors
d'un débat organisé avant le congrès la
nuit c'est un récit en construction et
c'est une volonté commune la volonté
effectivement de continuer ensemble de
chercher loyalement ensemble le chemin
qui permet de d'avancer parce que la
réalité elle nous a pas échappé c'est
quand même que quand la gauche est
divisée
elle perd deuxième tour jeudi prochain
Oli et force sera opposé à Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol le maire de Rouen qu'est-ce
qui se joue Jean-Luc vous redonne la
parole qui ce qui se joue actuellement
c'est l'avenir du Parti socialiste
c'est toujours un moment donné l'avenir
du Parti socialiste moi je trouve que
c'était plus la l'avenir de Monsieur
Ford en l'occurrence mais mais parce que
je pense qu'il y a pas un immense en jeu
moi ce que je pense là dessus c'est que
je pense que le Parti socialiste en tant
que structure politique c'est mort
exactement en revanche je pense que la
sociale démocratie comme courant
politique c'est loin d'être mort c'est
un espace ça continue à avoir un espace
dans la société pour des raisons
culturelles sociologiques historiques ce
que je pense c'est que les parties sont
mortelles et que les courants de pensée
ne meurent pas dans la même avec la même
dans le même timing que les partis
politiques
et la France insoumise il existe un
espace qui n'est pas rempli par le Parti
socialiste c'est-à-dire que surtout il y
a un espace interne au macronisme quand
tu auras plus Macron mais c'est ça
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire ces gens là
pour une part ils sont
sociaux-démocrates les gens qui ont voté
pour pour Macron ça existe pas le
macronisme n'a pas un truc politique qui
est le macronisme c'est il y a le en
même temps mais enfin c'est un peu léger
pour dire
mais mais comme partout comme partout
honnêtement comme comme le Parti
socialiste d'autres opportunistes c'est
le parti socialiste qui qui est dans
l'anus moi je pense là-dessus que je me
disais en ce matin en écoutant le
résultat de l'élection comme quoi on
peut atteindre du syndrome de Stockholm
et être élu patron d'un parti en réalité
c'est ça l'histoire c'est qu'aujourd'hui
le PS il est heureux d'être
otage de la lutte parce qu'il n'a pas
d'autre choix parce que ça survie c'est
d'être tâche pas qu'on touche au cœur du
sujet là n'oublions pas personne ne
susceptible de bébé d'oublier autour de
cette table que dans quatre ans il y a
une élection présidentielle et que
Emmanuel Macron ne sera pas candidat on
sait qu'il y aura alors ce sera Marine
Le Pen Jordan Bardella peu importe il y
aura un candidat extrême droite qui sera
très puissant nous disent les sondages
il y a d'assez bonne raison de penser
qu'il y aura un très fort candidat
d'extrême droite qu'est-ce qu'il y aura
en face qu'est-ce qui aura en face c'est
de l'intérêt du pays quoi qu'on pense
qu'il y ait en face une offre sérieuse
or
l'un des impacts les plus puissants de
l'aventure macroniste qui a plein
d'avantages par ailleurs j'en suis bien
d'accord et qui est admirable du point
de vue de la réalisation technique c'est
que il a éliminé tout ce qui pouvait
éventuellement ressembler et là Jean-Luc
a raison à
la tradition sociale démocrate mais
aussi à la tradition chrétienne
démocratique centriste et libéral c'est
deux familles là pourquoi les gens y
attendent pourquoi il y a tant
d'abstention aux élections parce que si
vous êtes vaguement chrétien démocrates
ou libéral d'une part ou si vous êtes
socialiste de gouvernement
social-démocrate d'autre part vous
n'avez plus d'offres en face alors du
coup soit vous votez Macron si vous êtes
à peu près compatible vous êtes pas trop
dégoûté par le déficit budgétaire pour
éviter le pire soit vous vous abstenez
après Macron il y aura plus l'option
Macron par définition donc qu'est-ce qui
aura et la résurrection de ces deux
familles est essentielle à mes yeux pour
des raisons à la fois intellectuelles
morales et d'efficacité si on est motivé
par l'idée que c'est pas une très bonne
idée de voir le rassemblement national
arriver au pouvoir qui peut faire
ressusciter et qui peut ressusciter ces
deux familles j'en sais mais on voit
bien que tactiquement ça peut pas être
Olivier fort Olivier fort il est ça fait
5 ans prisonnier syndrome de Stockholm
et de toute façon sans la nuit
socialiste quel bilan vous en tirez-vous
de Rosine alors bien je vais redescendre
au niveau des élections je pense que
c'était l'élection n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance il y a une prochaine
élection qui se va se dérouler qui va en
avoir beaucoup plus sur les élections
européennes parce que élections
européennes ou scrutin proportionnelle
ça va permettre de qualifier exactement
les forces politiques en présence là on
se compte et on voit bien d'ailleurs que
les écologistes veulent absolument pas
des listes communes etc on va voir là où
je rejoins tout à fait Philippe c'est
quand il dit l'élection présidentielle
va être la chose absolument primordiale
c'est-à-dire que ceux qui sont ont
constitué le macronisme d'un côté la
droite modérée et de l'autre la gauche
social-démocrate vont se retrouver dans
des cartes redistribuées et
effectivement la stratégie de Livier
est une stratégie mortifère alors que la
stratégie de LR est beaucoup plus
construite parce que comme on voulait
vous que les
ceux qui viennent de la gauche se
retrouvent dans une structure telle que
la Nuxe elle est beaucoup trop éloignée
idéologiquement
ils ne peuvent pas y aller tandis que la
droite modérée LR a une très belle carte
à jouer avec la fin du macronisme oh je
dis pas qu'elle va la prendre parce
qu'ils disent bon je crains qu'il n'est
pas tout à fait compris le ce qui est en
train de se jouer sauf que bon sur les
retraites il paraissent peut-être avoir
tiré un bord
vous dites que la stratégie d'Olivier
Faure au Parti socialiste est mortifère
c'est pour ça que tout alliance
officieuse et officielle
quand même que Jean-Luc Mélenchon tout
aussi critiquable qu'il est à quasiment
réussi son pari électoral il est passé
qu'on parle de social-démocratie mais
j'en ai Jean-Luc Mélenchon et pour moi
le dîner héritier de la
social-démocratie ici il y a une société
démocratie Jean-Luc Mélenchon on est
aujourd'hui le représentant le plus
éminent alors là mais c'est une évidence
mais ce que je pense que c'est sûr de
l'association très rapidement regardez
très rapidement regardez le programme
c'est un programme de gauche hyper
classique très rapidement donc je vais
faire une simple
est-ce que le Parti socialiste centrale
peut redevenir un parti dominant
aujourd'hui en 2027 je pense que le
Parti socialiste en tout cas si les
socialistes confirme le choix d'Olivier
fort en jeudi prochain remettre le Parti
socialiste au centre du jeu politique et
électoral ça c'est une certitude qui
peut devenir un premier parti de France
irrésistible pour Olivier Faure et pour
l'appareil du parti c'est que c'est ce
dispositif là qui leur permet d'avoir le
plus d'élus le plus de crédit de
maintenir le plus de permanence il y
aurait pas de critères il faut rappeler
une chose c'est qu'il n'y aurait pas de
groupe parlementaire socialiste si
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
vous savez très bien quand même
si vous avez vu
le président
Jean-Luc Jean-Luc vous avez pas écouté
le président grâce à vous présente
merci le PS est devenu les bergers de la
nuque bon on a entendu le Président il
faut qu'on avance jusqu'où doit-on
soutenir l'Ukraine face à la Russie
c'est notre cinquième thème alors où
l'on se parle les combats sont toujours
acharnés dans l'est du pays et l'Elysée
sans bien déterminée à accompagner Kiev
jusqu'au bout écouter Emmanuel Macron
lors de ses vœux pour la nouvelle année
mes chers compatriotes je veux ici et ce
soir en votre nom dire à nos amis
ukrainiens
vous respectons et nous vous admirons
votre combat pour la défense de votre
nation est héroïque et il nous inspire
et durant l'année qui s'ouvre nous
serons sans faillir à vos côtés nous
vous aiderons jusqu'à la victoire et
nous serons ensemble pour bâtir une paix
juste et durable voilà dans la foulée
l'Elysée annoncée pour la première fois
que la France allait livrer des chars de
fabrication
occidentale à l'Ukraine Rosine un cap
est passé et franchie dans le soutien
français à l'Ukraine et je pense que ce
cap était absolument nécessaire on
défend les valeurs de la démocratie on
en a beaucoup parlé démocratie dans
notre dans notre rencontre de ce matin
il est tout à fait cohérent d'aller plus
loin dans le soutien dans le soutien
l'Ukraine Emmanuel Macron a souvent été
critiqué pour la tiédeur de soutien
français à l'Ukraine c'est un moyen
voilà de faire taire les critiques
Philippe je crois pas que ce soit le
seul objectif ce qui est vrai il y a eu
un changement quand même moi ce qu'on
m'a dit je ne sais pas si c'est vrai
c'est que le président avait une espèce
d'ambition de prix Nobel de la paix et
que donc ils gardaient pour des raisons
j'allais dire quasiment personnel de
statures de une position très très en
retrait pour essayer
pour essayer d'accoucher une forme
d'accord
écoutez moi on me l'a dit assez bonne
source à plusieurs reprises peu importe
en tout cas ce qui est vrai c'est que
Emmanuel Macron était très très en
dessous de la main par rapport à tous
nos comparables en Europe bon moi je
pensais que c'était une énorme erreur
parce que effectivement même si
l'Ukraine n'est pas irréprochable le
crâne des corrompu le crâne a des tas de
l'Ukraine incarne aujourd'hui la
résistance à l'agression indéfendable de
la Russie donc pour moi le soutien doit
être absolument assuré aux Ukrainiens
parce que si on ne soutient pas les
Ukrainiens dans cette période là non
seulement on ne fait pas notre boulot du
point de vue moral du point de vue de
l'Alliance naturel que nous devons avoir
avec les vraies démocraties qui se
battent contre les régimes autoritaires
mais surtout le coup suivant c'est la
Pologne les Pays-Bas etc
jusqu'à jusqu'à la victoire qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire la victoire
de tous les territoires qui s'occupent
plus la crise donc ça veut dire qu'on
est prêt à mettre tous les moyens pour
la victoire de l'Ukraine
sur l'Ukraine c'est une question
fondamentale donc je me moque des états
d'âme ou des ambitions personnel ou des
éléments tactiques de de Macron
c'était très bizarre de savoir
d'ailleurs s'il y a un tournant ou pas
simplement je veux dire là-dessus mon
sentiment il faut aller jusqu'au bout
nous n'avons pas le choix il n'y a pas
d'alternative la seule alternative c'est
de soutenir les Ukrainiens en leur
laissant la maîtrise de décider quand il
décideront d'arrêter s'ils arrêtent ça
veut dire quoi c'est eux qui le
dessinent c'est eux qui le décident si
vous êtes envahi en France ce ne sont
pas les Américains qui vous disent vous
ne prenez pas l'Alsace et la Lorraine
vous le laissez pendant en 45 vous
laissez une partie de votre territoire
où vous abordez vous abandonnez une
partie des territoires c'est leur sang
donc c'est décidé de décider jusqu'où
ils iront et c'est notre devoir de les
soutenir jusqu'où ils iront dans la
reconquête de leur territoire rapidement
pierre la France Emmanuel Macron quel
rôle peut-il jouer aujourd'hui sur la
scène diplomatique mais je pense que la
question c'est pas vous qui l'a posé mal
parce que c'est la question qui
au centre de toutes les attentions sur
ce que c'est Macron mais non
mais c'est parce que le problème c'est
pas que la France le problème c'est
qu'il y a il y a des il y a des
décisions qui sont prises à géométrie
variable et on voit bien que les
décisions qui vont être prises par la
Pologne est-ce qu'il faut augmenter la
les aides à l'Ukraine peut avoir des
incidences sur la Pologne et s'il y a
des incidents sur la poignée ont des
répercussions sur l'Europe et donc la
France donc moi ce qui m'embête c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des décisions qui
sont prises de manière unilatérale et
qui a pas trop de concertation justement
sur comment on fait pression sur la
Russie et là je pense que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est invité donc l'émission
hier soir elle a beaucoup insisté
là-dessus c'est vrai qu'il faut aussi
savoir repenser nos institutions
internationales pour pouvoir peser
davantage sur la Russie sur l'Iran avec
en prenant en compte aussi des
puissances émergentes je pense au
Pakistan qui sont des des pays avec
lesquels il faut continuer de discuter
la semaine dernière dit être ouvert un
dialogue avec l'Ukraine à condition que
l'Ukraine accepte les nouvelles réalités
territoriales comment font interpréter
ça Rosine c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de
négociation parce
demande finalement qu'on revienne au
statuts qui a justement déclenché la
guerre c'est absurde
il ne peut pas ne pas faire semblant
d'être pour la paix quand on fait la
guerre il faut toujours dire qu'on est
prêt à l'arrêter mais en réalité il en a
pas la moindre intention en tout cas il
peut pas se permettre de céder un pouce
du terrain sauf sur la contrainte
évidemment et c'est tout ce qui est en
train de se jouer c'est ce qu'on va
mettre en face et c'est encore en train
de se faire mettre en face de Poutine
suffisamment d'armes pendant
suffisamment longtemps parce que faut
jamais oublier que le temps était un
ingrédient extrêmement important dans ce
genre de situation la guerre pendant six
mois un an etc mais les Russes sont
probablement prêts à faire la guerre
pendant plusieurs années est-ce que le
soutien occidental durera plusieurs
années c'est une question importante
chaque semaine on termine l'émission par
un top flop je vous propose je vous pose
à chacun une question simple quelle est
la personnalité a marqué l'actualité en
bien ou en mal Jean-Luc vous commencez
votre top votre flop
assez curieusement mais je trouve bien
j'étais frappé par les déclarations de
Robert Ménard qui a une capacité de
revenir sur son parcours sur ce qu'il a
fait dans les dernières périodes et je
trouve que quelqu'un qui s'est tellement
engagé avec Marine Le Pen tellement
engagé avec Zemmour qu'a dit des choses
tellement effroyables sur les questions
de l'immigration qui dit aujourd'hui
écoutez je vais vous dire la vérité je
me suis trompé c'était des conneries je
trouve que c'est assez courageux et
intéressant celui le flop on s'est
quitté j'avais fait un flop la dernière
émission j'avais dit oh là là le Noël le
Great c'est il a il a il a un ballon à
la place de de la tête c'est devenu une
balle de ping-pong chacun tu le verra
plus le remercier pierre votre flop mon
top je suis souvent en désaccord avec
elle elle est plutôt de droite mais pas
que elle a écrit beaucoup elle sort
souvent masquée le soir dans les
théâtres elle est souvent vêtue de rose
de verre de bleu de jaune je suis je
suis je suis rosé
c'est sympa j'ai lu son 682 jours le bal
des hypocrites et on se marre on apprend
des choses et donc bravo pour ça Rosine
parce qu'on vous connaît tous les gens
qui ne vous regardent vous connaissent
pour votre en parler et je peux vous
assurer que dans son livre il y a de
quoi
avoir de la matière à débattre dans les
repas de famille et pas que mon flop est
pour Olivier du soft parce que il est
celui qui porte la réforme des retraites
et pardon de le voir toujours vous
parliez de RAM tout à l'heure mais
sortir les rames pour essayer de se
justifier comment toute sa carrière
politique a été construite justement
l'engagement profondément à gauche et
profondément
anti-augmentation de l'âge départ à la
retraite et aujourd'hui celui qui
propose le français de le faire donc la
crédibilité est quand même largement
attachée il a ouvert les yeux tout
simplement votre top votre pierre votre
top
si c'est toujours pierre dites à
certains de choses qu'on partage mon top
je suis d'ailleurs un peu ennuyé de le
dire en top mais c'est quelque chose de
tellement émouvant et incroyable c'est
Mahamad Mehdi Karami c'est-à-dire ce
jeune iranien de 22 ans qui a été pendu
samedi dernier et qui dit
c'est évidemment qui dit à ses parents à
son père ils ont prononcé ma sentence
c'est l'exécution ne dit rien ne dis
rien à ma mère et ça c'est c'est une
émotion absolument incroyable et puis
alors mon flop c'est du Biden parce que
vraiment gérer cette histoire de
documents financiers qu'ils ont oublié
dans une armoire qu'on retrouve et puis
alors il y a des documents qu'on
retrouve dans son garage puis une
feuille comme ça dans sa bibliothèque et
la façon dont il gère la communication
sur cette affaire en bafouillant en
disant n'importe quoi véritablement
amener de tels éléments ces
les difficultés de la coplione c'est
l'américaine on peut lui trouver
éventuellement les circonstances
atteignent entre moi mon top c'est c'est
le ministre de l'Éducation pas Ndiaye
parce que je trouve que c'est courageux
et bienvenu de renforcer la maîtrise de
l'orthographe enfin de tenter de vous
dire de l'éducation nationale
en l'occurrence je crois que c'est c'est
c'est lui le flop si c'est la mort dans
l'âme parce que je pense que c'est une
association qui qui est dans le comment
dire dans l'objectif est louable mais je
pense que les rapports Oxfam le dernier
vient de sortir les rapports Oxfam sont
toujours tellement biaisés tellement
plein de préjugés tellement fait pour
démontrer quelque chose que d'ailleurs
souvent il ne démontre pas vraiment si
on fait les objections scientifiques qui
s'imposent que c'est vraiment dommage
d'avoir voilà ce type de publication de
cette qualité là alors qu'encore une
fois le sujet mérite mieux merci merci à
tous les quatre c'est la fin de cette
émission merci d'avoir participé merci à
vous derrière votre écran me dit dans
l'oreillette que vous êtes de plus en de
nombreux à nous regarder merci beaucoup
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez revoir
cette émission en replay et en podcast
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine même
jour même heure même endroit bye bye
[Musique]